[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute erdbeer
tiramisu warum machen wir das weil er
das so wollte
ich habe euch nämlich vor einigen
stunden auf instagram gefragt könnt mich
nämlich heute morgen nicht so recht
entscheiden soll ich jetzt das erdbeer
tiramisu machen oder eine himbeereis
torte und vielen dank dass ihr mir meine
entscheidung abgenommen habe ich bin
übrigens das hin der also diese hinweist
hatte dies auch super lecker falls ihr
die trotzdem sehen möchte dann schreibt
sie mich hier unten in die kommentare
aber heute geht es nur um unser erdbeer
tiramisu und hier habe ich auch schon
die zutaten sehr überschaubar wir
benötigen zum trinken orangensaft dann
ganz standardmäßig löffelbiskuits für
die creme habe ich hier einmal
magerquark und mascarpone vanille
extrakt und erdbeer zero findet in jedem
gut sortierten supermarkt puderzucker
zum süßen und selbstverständlich frische
erdbeeren okay lasst uns beginnen mit
der einfachsten creme der welt wir
nehmen jetzt unsere vier zutaten fünf
verdammt fünf sind und die geben wir
jetzt in eine schüssel und verrühren das
dann ich nehme heute mein handrührgerät
ich musste noch nicht mal ein
handrührgerät benutzen ihr könnt noch
einfach ein schneebesen nehmt dann wäre
das jetzt ein rezept ganz ohne maschine
[Musik]
du kannst du etwa anfang ja klar heute
muss es schnell gehen das ist die creme
das ist die creme die habe ich
vielleicht 30 sekunden gerührt und jetzt
geht es weiter hier mit unserem
löffelbiskuits für zwei sekunden
eintauchen
ja und dann ab in die form damit jetzt
ist der boden voll mit den
löffelbiskuits und als nächstes geben
wir die hälfte unserer creme da drauf
und dann müsste auch nicht so ordentlich
sein weil danach geben wir die erdbeeren
mit dazu
[Musik]
die erdbahn sind jetzt drauf die habe
ich richtig schön in kleine stückchen
geschnitten ein teil bewahrte ihr euch
von den am besten auf dann machen wir
nämlich gleich erst bergtour raus und
jetzt sind durch eine zweite lage
löffelbiskuits auch wieder für zwei
sekunden ein drucken und dann darauf
geben und da könnt ihr auch ein bisschen
an drücken damit die erdbeeren so in die
creme versinken
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die restliche creme auch
noch drauf verteilt und extra so ein
bisschen unregelmäßig damit dass die
luftigkeit zum vorschein bringt also ja
so sollten künftig müssen also ist
schmeckt auch nämlich sehr frisch und
luftig habe auch extra keine sahne
benutze ich wollte das leicht haben und
jetzt habe ich hier noch einen teil der
erdbeeren in meine schüssel gegeben und
das werde ich jetzt pürieren ihr könnt
jetzt noch ein bisschen zucker dazugeben
aber meine erdbeeren sind süß genug
deswegen das ist ohne zucker und jetzt
kuriere ich das ganz einfach das ist
jetzt mein erdbeerpüree und es gebe ich
jetzt aber noch kurz zur seite steht das
jetzt nur schon einmal vorbereitet ich
möchte jetzt meinen tiramisu aber noch
kühlen damit ich auch schöne stücke
herausschneiden können
natürlich könnt ihr das auch jetzt schon
anscheinend ist es auch sofort servier
bereit aber besser schmeckt wenn es
durchzieht weil erstens werden die
löffel bis gibt's noch mal richtig schön
weich auch von innen und zweitens wird
die creme ganz leicht fest schmeckt aber
trotzdem richtig fluffig möchte
unbedingt dass ihr diese sap bcm ist man
ausprobiert ich dekoriere das ganze
später noch natürlich mit dem erdbeben
hier habe ich noch ein paar
aufgeschnitten ehrt bin und ich suche
mir gleich noch etwas minze ab weil ich
kenne minze passt auch immer perfekt
jetzt verraten wir mal in den
kommentaren was ist aktuell eure
lieblings frucht meine ist erdbeer ich
könnte im moment so viel erdmann essen
ich mache mir auch abends immer jungs
mit erdbeeren haben sie liebt bananen
über alles also schreibt wenn man die
kommentare das würde mich sehr
interessieren
ansonsten schreibe ich euch in die
infobox die genauen mengenangaben einmal
aufklappen screenshot einkaufen gehen
und nachmachen und im besten falle
hinterlasse dem ich hier einen
deutlichen nach oben und abonniert main
kanal kostenlos dann verpasst ja auch
nichts mehr
gerne könnt ihr uns auch auf instagram
folgen da könnt ihr dann auch mitmachen
bei den abstimmungen denn wir fragen
euch hin und wieder was wollt ihr sehen
oder bgh können auch den hamster folgen
kann ich auch mal eine infobox
reinschreiben
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal auch wieder dabei sind auf
die skating skis
[Musik]